j'accueille maintenant un grand ami de
laurent gerra c'est pierre bellemare
moi ça va ça va bien vous connaissez
tous le monde harlem désir oui oui bien
sûr marion cotillard taxi un taxi 2 puis
d'autres choses richard anconina six
pack pour connaissez et laurent gerra
contre les gens de plus surtout à vous
j'ai raconté du souvenir français oui il
avoua delnard
bon alors vous présentait sur france 3
les bêtises de monsieur pierre oui
produit par nagui oui et de nîmes a
sorti voilà et ça marche vachement bien
ça fonctionne ça fait 25 % de parts de
marché sur une chaîne dans la moyenne et
18 donc on ne peux que vous féliciter
oui mais ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
la recrudescence pas compte de ce
système ouais toutes les chaînes sans
exception font des émissions de bêtises
moi je pense pas de vieux bouts de film
c'est un peu la télévision de faire
ailleurs maintenant et tout à fait non
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on prépare
pour arthur dans le disant cirque on
fait des trucs ici qui pourra utiliser
dans dix ans mais sympa non travaille
pour lui bon alors vous êtes là pas pour
parler des bêtises de monsieur pierre
qu'on regarde régulièrement vous êtes là
pour parler d'un livre
s'appelle empreinte de la bête
l'empreinte de la dette chez albin
michel valet crise et avec jean-marc
epinoux et jean-françois namias
absolument c'est 50 histoires où
l'animal a le premier rôle
[Musique]
bien alors eu
donc vous avez votre première émission
de télé achat en 87 et vous quel effet
la première émission de télé achat en 87
oui en france oui j'ai cet honneur le 5
octobre 1981 ça j'ai vendu je peux vous
dire ce que j'ai vendu dirigé mardi y
avait il y avait 2 e oui mais un intrus
geof d'autruche assure un petit seul
petit saute-vent ouattara mais voilà il
y avait un service de couteau oui la
yole voilà il y avait une lampe à
pétrole qui ressemble à une grosse loupe
et qui est avec une mèche en fibre de
verre inusable il s'était fait par des
haies des souffleurs de verre américain
oui oui c'est vrai artisan américaine
n'est pas ça venait pas de là jean guy
panont on se souvient particulièrement
parce que vous voulez garder parce que
ces objets certaines oui j'ai chez moi
la loupe j'ai chez moi leur faisons des
shebab absolument j'ai acheté un nom
incroyable d'objets au téléachat vous
attendez je précise toujours au prix 1
parce que la pire des choses quand on
est commerçant vous ne savez c'est de
céder aux avances des phones qui sont
toujours en train de dire je peux vous
faire un prix très intéressant
là vous êtes foutu parce qu'évidemment
force et moi vous êtes totalement france
musées moi je trouve ça formidable parce
que quand j'ai vu le spectacle je
sais bien je veux parodie très bien mais
il ya toujours ce problème vous le savez
les imiter ne sont jamais totalement
convaincu limitation des moyens que vous
diriez absolue non mais je sais aussi
mais nous mais nous avions été voir
alors avec je me suis acharné vous vous
en souvenez certainement oui 1dans un
spectacle au casino de paris et nous
bavardions charles s'il ya quelqu'un dé
d'imiter ses biens lui bon et nous nous
nous échangions nos impressions limitée
et c'est vrai que ni l'un ni l'autre
nous avions l'impression réellement
d'être bien limitées quoi je peux vous
dire à coeur il ya sauf le respect que
je vous dois à chaque fois je vous
entends parler maintenant oui vous voyez
laurent gerra grèce et l parce que
maintenant blanc faire s'écraser dans
une eau film sébastien ou dit bonsoir
thierry vous me parlez oui je me placer
l'élève faut pas mal je suis désolé puis
je vous demanderai une chose simplement
chers amis c'est de ne pas me faire
aller aux
là ça se termine comme ça
la fait souffrir votre femme votre lame
cela ne fait pas marrer obligatoire au
nom non semaines ont l'horloge et bien
oui totalement rodé bien alors
maintenant ce que je vous demanderais
c'est de vendée nous votre livre comme
si vous étiez au téléachat voilà tient
ce livre extrêmement commode car nous
avons étudié le format pour que une fois
ouvert exactement la moitié il recouvre
parfaitement le visage les jours
d'ensoleillement un peu et vous
permettre de rester sur la plage donc
tranquillement sans prendre de coups de
soleil merci
alors on se livre est assez étonnant
quand même au delà de roulades tout
c'est à dire que c'est des histoires
d'animaux absolument incroyable par
exemple il ya le les chevaux des cerfs
feld région qui ont fasciné le kaiser
guillaume ii c'est des chevaux qui
savait trouver les racines carrées oui
alors évidemment ces miracles en
respiration extraordinaire c'est le
connaît mal en ce sens je suis un couple
de chevaux donc les il avait un mec bien
tresseur et avec leurs jambes et leurs
sabots il tapait au sol et donner les
réponses donc on leur donnait un chiffre
et il donnait
la racine carrée voilà où là où même la
racine cubique alors bien sûr ça
paraissait totalement éblouissant est
époustouflant mais on a fait des
quantités de deux tests on a essayé de
2,2 de piéger le dompteur et
régulièrement les chevaux répondez
correctement donc on n'a pas connu comme
pour me rémy roca qui était un numéro
très serré de divination on n'a pas
connu le truc et comme pour me ramener
me revenir au score on pourrait dire que
c'est fantastique c'était vrai c'est
encore plus formidable si c'est faux bon
voilà mais voilà alors et sylvain mirouf
que vous connaissez et m'a dit l'autre
jour qu'il avait à document comme quoi
le secret avait été pénétrait et qu'il
allait m'apporter leur j'attends soirée
fut en rien cette histoire est que des
histoires absolument extraordinaire
évidemment avec vous et les 6 heures de
crimes qui sont prêts à le chien qui
décroche le téléphone pour faire peur
aux cambrioleurs absolument c'est ça sur
des gens qui sont assiégés par des
cambrioleurs le chat s'est sauvé bien
entendu et abandonnant au monde elle est
forcément par hasard mais c'est hazard
qui veut bien les choses il décroche le
téléphone on est à l'époque où le
central est relié au téléphone les vieux
téléphones d'autrefois ou en passer par
un central pour les communications
l'opératrice qui repèrent le numéro
puisque c'est le numéro de téléphone
quand le téléphone se décrochent dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe à l appel
elle n'entend rien et puis d'un seul
coup d'un seul elle entend le chat
miauler devant l'appareil essayer
quelque chose qui ne va pas chez les ath
l ailier envoie la police et on a des
lecteurs donc c'est bien le choc des
images histoire comme ça non j'adore
c'est génial car il ya les corbeaux
aussi qui a taclé qui attaquent les est
oui alors oui on s'aperçoit qu'ils jeu
coop carriole inventé et moi
personnellement je l' ai vu dans mon
jardin cette histoire j'ai à chaque
semaine mythique et très gros et un jour
il sait il s'est tapé si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi petit poussin
de pee wee et la zoophilie se sont
rassemblés ou de celui lots attaqués
sont descendus en cliquez sur lui des
pires ont attaqué le chat qui venait de
la bouffe est un petit vous méritez bien
mais ce qui est étonnant c'est que
pendant au moins un mois il n'a pas pu
sortir dans le jardin à chaque fois
qu'il sort peut dépister les enfants et
c'est ce qui est arrivé à ce qu en fait
c'est la même histoire c'est un chien
qui s'empare d'un bébé corbeau voilà et
évidemment les cordeaux sont rendus fous
par ça et se met à attaquer bien sûr la
propriétaire du chien vous êtes à côté
de son chéri régissant extraordinaire il
ya bon va pas tout vous raconter mais
les araignées venimeuses c'est à dire la
wii la fille en afrique du sud qui fait
tué sa soeur par des araignées
venimeuses elle mais qu'elle met dans
son disque est assez sympathique une
autre histoire extraordinaire c'est
celle de vos parents qui se sont
rencontrés vos parents se sont
rencontrés dans un bal qui s'appelait le
magic city absolument et qui était alors
ça c'est aussi extraordinaire de ce bal
était situé 15 rue cognacq-jay mais
quand on connaît votre carrière à
l'endroit où il ya eu après les studios
de télévision oui ils se sont rencontrés
là oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs
pourquoi est ce que les allemands
puisque ce sont les allemands qui ont
choisi le 15e reconnaissent pas les
français du tout pendant la guerre les
allemands installés sur cet emplacement
donc leur studio de télévision à
destination des soldats qui était en
convalescence dans la région parisienne
voilà quoi quoi servez ce studio est
donc il s'était installé tout simplement
sur les restes de mère de mutu magic
city il y avait donc une senne tournante
qui a utilisé ensuite la télévision
d'ailleurs pour ses premières émissions
de variétés par vos parents votre père
est un aristo il s'appelait deux stèles
d'ailleurs votre fils qui fait du
téléachat sa femme sa maman s'appelle
comme ça c'était la baronne de style lui
s'appelle marco de moi à oui s'était
mariée avec un roturier qui savait
bellemare ait été dans le pays d'art en
algérie sous une fine art devant votre
mère c'est une petite couturière de
montmartre ah oui mais votre père donc
fils d'aristo et votre mère dont il y
avait vraiment un problème enfin pas un
problème il ya une vraie différence de
classe oui ils se sont aimés
extraordinairement beau parent c'est à
dire que même quand votre père avait
décelé des problèmes de faire un moment
été obligé de vendre j'étais ruiner
votre terre tellement l'emprunt russe et
est obligé de vendre des livres en porte
à porte donc c'était un c'est très
difficile pour lui faisait déjà du
téléachat y arriver il sonne et que
c'était déjà assez de famille
il a d'abord entendu de la colle ouais
dans les pays où avaient lieu les
batailles de la guerre de 14 beaucoup de
choses à côté
ensuite il ya les grands effets ici il
s'est mis aux livres et il y reste et
marchands de livres toute sa vie se
retrouver de temps en temps à l'hôtel
avec votre mère pendant des années comme
ça bien ils auraient ils partaient sur
la route on peut dire cinq jours sur
sept et en effet ils se donnaient rendez
vous se téléphoner pas parce que le
téléphone on l'utilisé très très peu
évoqué très peu de téléphones nous
n'avions pas le téléphone bon et avant
de partir il faisait donc quand je
reviens je t'attends à tel endroit à
telle heure et se donnaient rendez vous
des amoureux et est donc évidemment y
passer une nuit d'amour folle à chaque
fois qu'ils se retrouvaient c'est donc
tout ils ont été à coup parfait et comme
toujours ce sont sur ces couples que
s'acharne les maladies les destins
divers et malheureusement ma mère est
morte d'une maladie terrible qui ronge
littéralement qui s'appelle à ste rose
en plaques et donc voilà donc ce bel
amour s'est terminée dans la douleur
total delà d'une maladie atroce alors à
17 ans et demi vous rentrez à la radio
avec jean-jacques vital jacques antoine
enfin les pères fondateurs de la radio
et la télévision française et alors là
vous inventer tous ensemble ce qui sera
la radio et la télé moderne alors des
jeux comme 100 francs par seconde cité
quoi 100 francs par seconde c'était des
gens qui est 100 francs par seconde
c'est génial temps qui tenait à mais
face à jean jacques vidal qui était
l'animateur de ce chat lui il savait
tout et les autres devaient temps qui te
n'égalise en vain mais alors il leur
arrivait quantité de choses
c'était une émission extrêmement visuel
d'ailleurs on est parti en spectacle
avec cette émission pendant des années
les gens se précipiter dans les salles
on était pop ou revoir ce spectacle très
vite avec littéralement fortune avec
cette émission
et en fait la radio faisait le reportage
en quelque sorte du spectacle alors des
émissions aussi vous avez fait des
premières grandes émissions vous
mobilisiez des gens vous êtes
formidables avec les ouvertures mais
avait surtout fait est formidable c'est
la naissance d'une chose qui alors est
inutilisé totalement à la radio n'a
jamais été utilisé ça paraît incroyable
et c'est ainsi on n'avait jamais eu
l'idée avant vous êtes formidables de
téléphoner à un auditeur pour autres en
relation avec lui donc c'est la première
fois qu'on utilise le téléphone et comme
on n'a pas de standard téléphonique à
europe 1 il ya strictement aucun
standard eh bien on va reprendre le
standard qui existe à l'époque ce sera
svp svp qui va devenir très très célèbre
grâce aux dossiers de l'écran 10 heures
alors bon il ya plein de la mission va
pas toutes les citer et la tête et les
jambes ya la caméra invisible il ya
cavalier seul ou laurent fabius a fait
ses débuts oui tout à fait les dossiers
extraordinaire alors il ya la chose la
chose c'est ça le faisait l'objet
mystérieux mais pas nous enfermer une
chez eux c'est le schmilblick ont choisi
c'est une chose est faite nous jouer la
wii alésia oui est-ce que la chose est
ronde la chose ce que je te j'ai choisi
que vous venez de choisir le nom
esi est ce que la chose est une femme
non elle se mange non marion
limal ben non justement
est-ce que la chose est dur oui parce
qu'ils rêvent à pau d'ousse après
l'amour
est ce qu'elle se mange c'est à dire
qu'elle se sucent haute à yahia je veux
je prends de comprendre
la chose est sucré non justement on
suscite beaucoup ça mais curieusement
c'est plutôt mais ma mère c'est un bâton
de réglisse c'est pas un bâton de
réglisse mais ça a de la forme en effet
d'un bateau du bois de réglisse non non
c'est pas du bois de réglisse baisser le
mot bois peut s'employer en ce qui le
concerne pas d'autres feux des pipes
c'est pas du bois dont on fait les pipes
mais c'est pas con sus quand même
écouter sa bouche tout seul ça bouge
tout seul à non mais on aime bien faire
bouger
bouger pardon pippa non c'est pas une t
il maintenant non pardon et du mois non
non caisse conçue sans fin qui est
toujours mâchouiller est lamentable un
chewing gum non si l'on glisse la langue
est en bois un bois un crayon en main
vous a fait comment
yanis qu'organise vous venez de gagner
la chose à
gagner quoi les gens à l'époque abbas
était là toujours l'histoire de la
cagnotte c'est à dire qu'on était tous
les jours tant dans la cagnotte est
toujours en trouver la cagnotte est non
mais y avait 100 francs dans la cagnotte
je suis un peu la rue alice de rtl oui
c'est la valise des retards et laurent
86 donc vous êtes viré à l'âge de 55 ans
est viré de la télé whissell
et alors là vous effectivement pour que
vos revenus financiers ne dépende plus
seulement
de votre carrière d'animateur c'est là
que vous intervenez vous inventez donc
le fameux téléachat oui enfin l'adapt
ouais on a frôlé les anciens en france
c'est ça on adapte pour la france une
idée américaine qui n'est pas du tout
fait aux états unis kovalev auteur
france car nous il va falloir s'intégrer
à un programme on va vers une émission
de télé achat alors que aux états unis
ce sont des chaînes de téléachats que ça
du magro soit tandis que nous nous
allons créer un programme d'une
demi-heure où on va prendre des zones
avec la cloche à trois matches avec la
cloche à 3h absolue bien on va faire une
petite intéressés quand on bouge pas
pendant le jingle vous le savez saint
pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il bouge voudront pas moi je peux pas
m'empêcher de sourire en regardant lui
bouche vous aimons pâques à vous êtes
joueur bien alors l'interview nul donc
chez les questions les plus cons
possible et les réponses des deux tonnes
possible on va voir est-ce que ça c'est
la question la première question c'est
la question qui nous a été donnée par
clotilde courau qui désormais est une
amie salut clotilde est ce que par amour
vous embrasse seriez sans fois de suite
des chaussettes sales
jeunes en amour oui par amour iv va
écouter malgré tout l'amour que je
pourrais avoir pour une dame je ne
supporterais pas qu'elle soit salle donc
je ne pourrais pas embrasser non plus
ses chaussettes sales et vous vous le
feriez marion non parce que je veux pas
que j'ai peur quelques clotilde courau
qui fasse ce genre de truc je pourrais
le faire si aussi là le propriétaire des
chaussettes est parti depuis très
longtemps à voilà assez beau cette vie
chasse du fait de jolis vous posez la
question c'est un petit geste par un
petit peu ah merde j'ai posé toutes les
questions sauf fétiche ou est-ce que
vous préfériez votre père votre mère
je vais vous dire très sincèrement ce
propos tellement con comme question 16
ans l'asec très complète moi je suis
incapable de répondre si bas si je vais
pas me répondre si si si il se trouve
que ma mère a été j'avais cinq ans quand
elle est tombée malade et donc j'ai
toujours vu une personne aux lits acquis
à la fin je faisais ces piqûre de
morphine ouais donc c'est vrai que la
personne vivante avec moi celui qui m'a
vraiment éduquer c'est mon père ouais et
donc finalement je pourrais dire que
j'aimais plus mon père que ma mère même
si ça paraît comme ça normal parce que
c'était une personne vivante alors que
j'avais en face de moi gamin une
personne uniquement malades qui était ma
maman est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
alors il ya un grand débat vous savez
que anconina qui se dit c'est pas
tomber si on préfère en général dire
qu'on préfère staline parce que l'idée
communiste way est une idée généreuse
alors que les néo nazis ne l'est pas
c'est ce qu'on dira jamais assez ce
qu'on dit moi personnellement je trouve
sur deux monstres absolument trigo
il n'y a aucune différence quoi c on les
aveux c'est vraiment laissé des frères
jumeaux mais ma préférence à vraiment
hitler ou staline moi je déteste plus
hitler parce qu'effectivement une cette
idée d' éradiquée de la surface de la
terre des gens parce qu'ils sont d'une
religion d'une origine les juifs les
tziganes ou les homosexuels bon mais
staline on peut lui en vouloir peut-être
autant parce qu'il a trahi une belle
idée ouais puis dans la tue quand même
où tu l'as tuée sambi
est ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en christophe dechavanne
nagui ou arthur
écoutez je pense celui qu'elle pût
difficulté actuellement donc je tiens
absolument à me réincarner en nagui oui
bon voilà assez gentil ces chrétiens ça
parce que c'est atteint parce que c'est
mon producteur
jeu c'est le meilleur coach que j'ai eu
ma garde côtes sont repartis avec des
bêtises de monsieur pierre je n'avais
pas fait de prime time depuis 86 ouais
bon donc il me fallait quelqu'un qui
murray après il me donne la pêche
comment un email et ça a été un coach
absolument extraordinaire donc c'est
bien le dire en tous les cas chez moi
j'aimerais bien ta guy ribes quel est
votre punition préférez vous préférez
être passé mort du piquet ou griffer
mort du pape un mort du pain c'est piqué
ou griffé à la morsure dans l'amour ça
existe quand il est chaud pierrot
oui mais je dirais qu'il fasse le plus
mal qu as tu sont horriblement mal et
pourtant c'est un temps il est chaud le
pire
est-ce que vous préféreriez pendant dix
ans c'est une vue de l'esprit bien sûr
pas de sexe ou pas mangé
pendant dix ans elle en disant pas de
sexe pas manger
c'est une façon de vous demander je
préférais baiser au bout fait en gros
ben je pense quand même que pour pour
partir sur 10 ans au bout comme à
vacquerolles on va forcément crever
c'est en revanche part il faut quand
même choisir de ne pas se taper qui
compte c'est le problème est d'accord
mais si vous êtes tout seul et cheveux
bien et à tête robinson crusoé
insupportable et enfin vendredi arriver
là quand même on se console vous êtes
d'accord
alors bon vous préféreriez être aveugle
et sourd ou amputé des bras et des
jambes non leur saison des cotonnades
etc et sur la contre attaque
aveugle et sourd ou alors amputé en bas
et bat au fond c'est quand même amputé
des bras et des jambes parce que aveugle
et sourd c'est quelque chose que je
dirais vous porter un slip un caleçon ou
rien un slip c'est très important on se
demande dès fois à quoi ça sert service
public là on le sait et oui voilà je
vous peut vous donner également des
mâles même marqué suisse très bonne
marque suisse quel est l'animal qui
embrasse le mieux l'animal qui embrasse
le mieux j'ai horreur de me faire
embrasser par les animaux ah bon j'ai
pas du tout jeune or pas du tout assez
marrant c'est un peu comme marion
cotillard alors j'adore j'adore me faire
masser par qui on voudra mais paparazzi
bord la dernière question pierre
bellemare comment vendriez vous un
vibromasseur qui se recharge sur
l'allume-cigare
[Rires]
je commencerai par dire
share and we l'objet que je vais vous
tendre doit absolument être utilisée sur
un parking et en aucun cas
pendant la marche des véhicules en effet
à partir du moment où vous avez branché
saïgas le vibromasseur que je vais
maintenant vous proposer
tout est possible le nirvana peut
arriver et donc il est impossible de
jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps est
en train de doubler nos deux chaînes de
deux dash sur le dos bravo région
[Applaudissements]
c'est un triomphe
pierre bellemare aurait lui aussi joué
dans un péplum les corrections
raté leur dicte leur nature et vous
abonner me vint plus bleue était un peu
ce bleu